hello and welcome
to this video this is just a really
short video to get you
up to date on what's happening over
the christmas days so i will be doing
some live shows
on chess 24 that's the first thing that
i want to mention
and i'm currently here on the youtube
page this is one way to go there you can
also go
on the chess 24 website i will be doing
shows starting tomorrow on the 24th
this will be an english show and then we
have english shows
every like four days uh at
noon noon center european time and there
are also
german shows which should pop up here
here now you see the german shows here i
mean
it's probably a little bit smallish but
this is on the 26th
the 30th and so on so if you want to
watch some
banter blitz shows on the chess 24
channels you can go on the german
channel or the english channel
here on youtube and catch them they are
also on the chess 24 website
which should work let me go on the chess
24 website
it's something else but you you'll get
there like here i am you're going to
watch or see and shows and
this is also a way to it's a little bit
cut off there i'm sorry but
you see my shows there so you will be
able to find them if you're interested
they're all um at noon center european
time so
before you probably meet family i don't
know it's all going to be very limited
anyway
this uh christmas so there are some live
shows there
i will also put something on youtube i'm
not quite sure maybe
tomorrow i have to see maybe before i do
the
the show at noon but that's not planned
yet
um also i wanted to mention that
let's go there that there is a chessable
sale the holiday sale um
for many of of course many courses and
yeah you see that they have money in the
rotation
so there is um they keep it simple it's
on sale
and fight like magnus the dirty harry
the lifetime repertoire c4 knight f3 the
new one
so all of my larger courses are on sale
so if you wanted to get
one of those this is a good opportunity
to save a lot of money
yeah and also make sure to join me for
the live shows they're also on twitch of
course so
you have many ways just uh search for
the chess 24 channels and
join you can also chat so
um happy to meet you there and there
will be some videos
on the channel but that is not planned
yet probably uh starting tomorrow
okay guys thanks a lot for watching